en Ciudad de México arrancó la segunda
Ronda de unas negociaciones muy
importantes para Colombia las del
gobierno de Gustavo Petro con la
guerrilla eln cuyo principal objetivo es
el cese del fuego bilateral porque lo
que un gobierno acuerda para alcanzar la
paz Es un acuerdo de estado en este
sentido este gobierno hace realidad el
principio de que los pactos son para
cumplirlos
Y es que este eventual acuerdo de paz
con el eln es una tarea pendiente del
gobierno desde hace años que en
noviembre tras cuatro años de suspensión
consiguió reanudar en Caracas sede de la
primera ronda de conversaciones y en
diciembre llegaron a acuerdos como la
liberación de Rehenes y la puesta en
marcha de acciones humanitarias pero sin
alcanzar el alto el fuego también han
tenido desencuentros como cuando el
presidente Petro anunció el cese al
fuego a partir del 1 de enero para ser
desmentido más tarde por la guerrilla
que aseguró que no se había llegado a un
acuerdo al respecto tras aclarar los
malentendidos en la agenda de esta
segunda ronda figura el famoso alto del
fuego la participación ciudadana en el
acuerdo y el establecimiento de un plan
de acción en definitivo cuya agenda
Busca acordar transformaciones y poner
fin al conflicto armado con la
determinación de lograr una paz integral
y duradera ahora se espera que las
conversaciones se prolonguen al menos
durante tres semanas cuando se verá si
ambas partes consiguen llegar al alto
del fuego que sería histórico ya que
tras el acuerdo de paz con las Farc en
2017 el eln es la última guerrilla que
sigue en activo en el país